good morning Grafton wait about the
geography are from have a good day
welcome to divorce session or webinar
session of what it means to a career
when it comes to adopting DevOps so my
name is Chandra mr I am certified DevOps
PMP prince2 ITIL expert Kobe tri-tip a
lead assessor at the same time I am a
practitioner related to ISO 20000 27,000
and 9001 practices for organizations it
has been 21 years in the industry now so
who has implemented various solutions
for organization keeping this best
practices in mind so DevOps is also so
one such moment so that we can
understand what it is so let us come to
the background of this particular
webinar or background of white divorces
coming so what is the reason behind
divorce being adopted by many
organization across the industry so
typically if you look at it I think more
of more most of you would acknowledge
this a product lifecycle would look like
this there is an introduction stage
where you conceptualize and product
inception happens then once it happens
that is evaluated evaluated for ROI
evaluated for its viability for
organizations and for the customers and
at the hardest stage you will understand
the high level requirement you will
understand the eye level requirement of
that particular product or the
requirement of a customer is actually
looking for the specific product or
service will capture and they'll agree
at this stage so has it Mon you design
your design and create the specific
product and then develop and it will be
ready for deployment so now this is a
stage where you from the conceptualizes
stage to actual realization of the
product it happens the one set is
deployed it is operational once it is
operational the actual product is seen
by customer actual services experienced
by customer so from there it starts in
terms of for improving the product in
terms of making it
better the line to the customers
business requirement and the
functionality will also be improved
based on the requirement of the
customers so it goes on as it goes on it
reaches a stage where it gets saturated
or that is the stage where protect our
retired where it is no more viable this
is a traditionally all of us know the
life cycle of any product or a service
now this creation is a journey from
nothing to something creation and then
you decline it there is a life cycle now
what is the gap in this there is a gap
identified the gap is in between dev and
ops here mostly we're speaking about the
required collaboration required
communication required time to market
required speed in terms of bringing the
product into the market requires been in
terms of enhancing the features etc so
keeping that in mind DevOps is being got
into the stage where it evolved and
still evolving and many organizations
adopted divorce and Burton very good
improvements are not small improvements
a huge improvement so the way what is
that gap why the gap is there which is
called there is a wall of confusion what
is that wall of conclusion dev is
focusing on doing more and more changes
into the environment so introduction of
a new modules introduction of product to
the environment configuration changes
new model introduction etc so it is time
driven scheduled to run projects which
is being happening at the same time and
product is introduced offs with the
limited information or limited
capabilities related to the product
depending on the day again they seek for
stability because of this the ownership
of ensuring the product is fulfilling
the business requirement is missing so
this goes on which has to be emphasized
mode which has to be given importance
this confusion goes on so this confusion
is created because of the importance
given by a div and the importance what
op sticks we will see that what is that
dev sees and op sees in the actual
real-life scenarios
so this one of confusion has to be
eliminated right so why there is a ball
of confusion what dave says what is the
perception Dave sees more argent date
driven projects fragile code going into
production because of the date driven
requirements release with turbulent
instance instance longer release cycle
to amortized cost of deployments
difficulty diagnosing wide deployments
are failing senior and constrained ops
racism less time to fix process problem
because they are not aware of it they
need to rediscover it backlog of
infrastructure projects that could fix
root cause and reduce cause tension
between dev and ops this is what Dave
sees let us look at other way so what
ops is so op C is fragile application
failing difficulty identifying root
cause taking too long to restore
services so why are they taking too long
to restore services they are not better
informed or they are not given addict
required information to work on that
particular product or service whenever
it has a deviation from its actual
behavior so unfinished planned project
work because of the pressure from the
customer or end-user it has been
implemented in ornament but ops does not
know to deal with it frustrate the
customer living market share decreases
missed Wall Street projections and empty
promises to share address it would look
like it is a scenario it would lead to
this because of which operation is
pressure pressure is to ensure the
product is more stable so the what
operations is what Dave sees according
their perception the other side of the
wall is always okay they are enjoying
that's what it looks like when reality
it is not now how do you eliminate this
wall of confusion do you have to bring
in a balance between extreme focus on
change your chest ability otherwise it
will not become successful organization
will be suffering so what business wants
has to focused upon and accordingly this
balance needs to be brought in this way
the DevOps started I think DevOps
inception actually got triggered in the
year two thousand seven and later it has
been studied for the DevOps days we're
done across the globe lot of interaction
semanas we're done and DevOps is formed
now visited a mature stage fully yes it
is at certain stage but it is still
maturing it is evolving however this
thought process has been adopted in many
unicorn organizations and they have
become successful to name them for
example is Amazon IBM for example then
what is divorce we understood why
divorce has brought in what is the gap
we have in the current industry
practices but what is this divorce a lot
of people will ask me the questions
during the sessions telling that easier
to tune he is that a process is that a
best practice process like itl PMP
brains too he is that a methodology what
is it let us look at it so divorce is a
cultural and professional moment that
stresses communication collaboration
integration between software developers
and IT operation professionals it is a
cultural movement which needs to
emphasize on the requirement of
collaboration integration and
communication between dev and ops so
today as we say well of confusion is
there between development and IT
operations so that has to be eliminated
by bringing this collaboration and
communication integration which leads to
responding to exhilarated demand for
quality software product and services
continuously acknowledges the
interdependence of IT functions because
they are well aware of what is been
happening around recognize the need for
culture improvements so one who
recognize yes they need their has a
requirement for improvement consciously
and then adopt it that culture is needed
the flexibility is needed that
willingness is needed supports and
villages agile in a native sm practices
traditionally if you think all of us
we're looking at waterfall methodology
so what is waterfall waterfall used to
take the entire view of products and as
a stages phases which used to do
creation of product or service
now AJ came in which actually emphasized
on quick succession doing it on a quick
succession with the Sprint's now a jail
is accepted practice for development so
focus of a jail today is on development
alone but is that looking the specific
product or services in a lifecycle
prospective of the product of service is
the one difference so to bring in that
thought it is also bringing out the
collaboration and thought process of
other best practices of G's in the
industry and today accepted practice is
a jai alai Eileen and I TSM practice
itsm stands for IT Service Management so
where you have more emphasis on
improving on a continual basis bringing
out more speed into a development and
deployment and operations and a jail way
of thinking in operations and
emphasizing quality from the date of
inception and looking at any product or
service a lifecycle prospective as told
in IT service management practices so it
encourages the use of automation with
one team one goal with extend beyond day
180 ops alone which has to make sense
for business what value developed is
looking to create it is cultured
automation measurement and shipping they
made the change in culture they need
culture which enables less hellos or no
silos if they should be collaboration
they should be sharing everything what
you do is to measure when you measure
only you understand the performance
insisting on it then bringing out more
and more automation by recognizing the
areas which actually has a repetitive
most frequently and simple tasks and
bringing out this automation part of in
development deployment testing
operations etc so more than anything
else DevOps is a cultural movement based
on human and technical interactions to
improve relationship and results this is
what a thought process so today's
confusion is DevOps is also look like
other practice where I have a specific
tool for divorce I will bring him there
is no specific tool for any best
practices it is the tool which suits the
requirement of organization to build
this culture automation measurement and
shaving as to be recognized by the
organization and adopted accordingly
what DevOps is not the earnest rotas
develops but what it is not it is not a
simply combining development and
operations team it is not n separate
function or a team which is established
in between Devon dogs to bring in
collaboration it is not that it is not a
specific tool and it is not a one
strategy for all who achieves update you
and it is not an automation alone it is
everything you need tool unit automation
you need a focused group to ensure the
development organization went well
moving from the current culture to non
DevOps culture to diverse culture you
need is for a specific focus group which
makes into the organization or entity
which is actually willing to bring in
the works in their organization so what
is the goal when the ops moment stretch
what should be the goal better align IT
responsiveness and capability to
business needs produce smaller more
frequent of releases reduce effort and
risk associated with software
development transition and operation
improve time to market improve quality
of code improve quality of software
deployments reduce cost of product
iterations in delays instill a culture
of communication collaboration improve
productivity improves ability in 280
requirement process looking at each of
the lines you may definitely ask the
question with my [ __ ] in your mind what
is that new English I am seeing your
goals every time I discuss itsm I speak
about having a capability required for
an organization as per the business
needs we speak about it at the same time
you will also speak about the soft
releases in agile methodologies more
frequent practice off releases or at the
same time we speak about taking a
requirement of communication time to
market collaboration we keep speaking
but what is the difference the
difference here is the difference
between speaking and doing all these
years we kept saying but we don't know
what how exactly it is required so now
since divorce has been coming it is a
conscious of
it will be put by organization and
organization putting towards it after
seeing the benefits the names i said
amazon and IBM which i said they are
consciously acknowledged and adopted and
they speak confidently today we adopt a
divorce and we see the benefits of it so
when you look at divorce don't look at
it as a tool don't look at as English
what is slowly as a goals it's about
achieving these goals and when i say i
am moving towards the ops and that
journey is not one day's journey we were
speaking about automation 10 years back
that automations has happened in many
processes but still that automation was
not with the intention of having a
cultural moment which brings in a
collaboration continuous flow of
creation of a products and having any of
your modules or software applications
ready to deploy stage this is what the
difference is and this has to happen
from every corner of organization
expected of the functions it is seen to
so what is a divorce approach so it's
all about the way the people think the
way the people interact the way the
people work the way they perceive about
themselves perceive about their
colleagues perceive me about their
managers perceive about their
organization perceive about their own
job role and their career progression so
people has to adopt a value which bring
in a practice in organization which
enables organization take you to next
level only then organization become
successful this is the core value which
which core requirement or for any
organization to have a cultural movement
to ensure organization goes in the
direction of achieve is energy achoo
those in a better way now what does it
adopt divorce does not say bring in a
new methodology instead DevOps says
understand the best practices properly
and have a collaboration we speak about
quality we speak about project
management we speak about service
management we speak about quality
various things we speak but are we doing
it consciously what we bring out the
collaboration there are we seeing the
value what we need it by bringing
everything together so successful day
offs relies on adoption
integration of multiple framework and
methodologies which fits into the Denver
Mint to bring in that specific outcome
what is needed by organization so devil
speaks about continuous development and
continuous delivery where you are making
application to be ready for deployment
always which means you're for seeing
your foreseeing the future of the
specific product or services proactively
and then you are making it ready today
once it is making it ready today you can
also make it modification required
toward up when you are actually
releasing it so more and more informed
team more and more aware team is always
ready to do the things differently and
bring that value to the system that's
why it says continuous business planning
collaborative development what is it
collaboration is being about dev and ops
collaboration when the collaboration
happens development is actually coming
to know the dynamics in operations at
the same time operation which never
involves in terms of why this product is
made and how it has been created it is
coming back and understanding what
happens in dev and they're sharing with
each other that's where collaborative
development happens then continuous
testing continuous religion deployment
and discontinuous religion deployment
happens because already that path is
defined you brought in the automation
more and more automation consciously
then continuous monitoring to improve
things contains customer feedback and
optimization some time you go to
customer deploy into production Norman
learn it and bring back feedback which
would bring in a product in a better way
which makes sense to the customer and
make business successful so there is a
continuous flow from left to right then
in second tears flow from right to left
and left to right when I say from
creation to production then a right a
left when I say production back to our
development now in between there is a
continuous learning which is happening
by testing it rigorously every stage and
introducing new models inducing
automation and you are using a right
tools so Jin Kim so who is actually a
writer of a book called Phoenix project
who spoke about DevOps and he is also a
specialist he brought out this
philosophy which says
central to DevOps philosophy is a
recurring flow of small releases
facilitated by automated configuration
test and closer collaboration between
developers and operations people so here
we are speaking about DevOps what is
happening from Delta offs you have
automatic testing that is from dev to
ops you have automated tests and
automated configuration from ops to do
there is a continuous monitoring and
feedback collaborative development and
continuous integration Sierra will take
an example which I myself come across
maybe last year I am saying about this
is about a automobile organization who
has an IT supporting that organization
for business now dealer management
system is one of the applications which
has to be enhanced based on the dynamics
of the market and pretty they were
struggling because of the application
which is not being working now we
brought in this concept of DevOps there
what happened the moment they learnt
they needs a collaboration of dev and
ops how to collaborate and way to
collaborate is immediate question which
has come in so why to collaborate at a
multiple lists of things which gave an
impression which gave a clarity that dev
is not even aware of the real life
scenario real environments interview
similarly offs does not have a clue
about what it takes for development to
bring out a product and they also used
to struggle coordinating would dare to
take up the specific incident which
occurs it used to delay and that was a
business impact for example you go on
bouquet vehicle maybe two wheeler maybe
car or any vehicle now you are if you as
a customer when you were booking or your
test drive require request is delayed
you may not go and buy the specific
vehicle from that particular dealer if I
go to a different dealer or a different
brand itself because that is a brand
image so this moment brought in the
clarity of collaboration needed the
amount of communication has to happen
and they created it and I was an active
part of it because since I cancelled
many organization I was an active part
of this movement and it was a huge
success the number of customers a number
of transaction which will say today
value it is increased 2,000 into X that
is a change it has happened and
application became quickly capable of
handling such an dat is anticipated and
predict what can be done in the next
stage this is what I have seen and there
is a classic example I again fold again
take it confidently because I have seen
this and I would handle it myself
through this philosophy of continuous
collaboration continuous communication
closest collaboration with dev and ops
understanding actual market dynamics by
dev and ops understanding their dynamics
at the same time business direction
things can move in as a required
direction for organization the
collaboration requirement communication
collaboration record mainly we need in
development operation and QA and it is
not limited to that so that is why are
we come across three best practices that
is agile lean and itsm so I ta sem best
practices today what we have is ideal
for lean we have six sigma and many
quality practices like kaisan you can
adopt anything which makes sense your
organization comes to that but
collaboration integration is very
important and that process has to be
there a gel-like scrum you can adopt any
of agile methodology which makes sense
to your organization but idea is to
bring in that collaboration and bring
their continuous delivery and deployment
which has to happen in an organization
for its success in the business to
compete in this competitive dynamic in
other word now finally what Forest
Service's says without good
interpersonal harmoni your business
cannot adopt to changes in competitive
landscape and this is the outcome of a
research from Forrester visit now
question here is we understood what is
DevOps we understood the why it has come
out but what is there for me when it
comes to my career what it how it makes
sense to my career and what is the
direction I need to take I am a
developer so should I become a fit i
learned divorce and become something
okay I'm a test engineer how divorce
would help me I am a data center
facility management personnel I am
infrastructure person
so all this is an IT infrastructure
application everything falls under 80 so
what is there in it for me what is there
in it from dev ops for me where the base
my career going towards what does the
change would happen in my career that we
need to understand that would actually
bring in more clarity and that is the
requirement of any professional to grow
in their career and contribute to the
organization contribute to themselves so
what is this career perspective and
comes to divorce there is popular
nomenclature called devops engineer
which is used on regular basis but easy
to a new job rule that we need to have a
clarity answer is there is no industry
recognized job description or formal
carrier track for devops engineer now
keep in mind this doesn't mean that your
career is not going in either direction
this is emphasizing on the point you
have a scale and you should sharpen that
scale on a continual basis you should
continuously learn then individuals who
fill this role may be developers insist
interested in deployment and system
administrators or in interest in
scripting and coding here we are
speaking about cross killing and
remember cross killing is not a noon
word what we are using it is used with
many organization many a times but how
consciously this is used and is that
related to business direction is that
link to business requirement that is the
missing link so you should have a people
who are dog or flexible and make sense
to the organization being part of that
organization so general characteristics
include for a person who involves in the
entity of DevOps has to contribute is a
technical talent to the business and
process improvement initiatives
proactively and should be comfortable
collaborating with others and there is
no se lo thinking expected that doesn't
make sense wants to be in the workplace
that promotes shared culture willingly
the person should be there in the
workplace or promotes a culture this is
what the willingness this is what the
adoption is what the flexibility
adopting the changing business
requirement deduct the technical changes
it is happening continuously learning
this should be the attitude and it has
to be demonstrated consciously without
even bringing out the thought of silos I
learnt it I am contributing to an
express interior the test happen under
content
is knowledge sharing should happen so
DevOps is not a new job role it is
better way of doing things and
achievement results on continual basis
so now how do you do that what is in it
for me as a professional yes I heard
this many times and how can i adopt so
remember without a commitment from
management without a conscious movement
initiated by management evolves cannot
happen so the officers to happen from
all the corners in the organization and
what it is they're for exhibit google
google also as our operative ups and
look at the way the culture divorce
sorry google has by adopting the ops if
someone has seen google they can see it
i have seen it same thing i've seen
amazon very closely IBM i have not seen
closely but i have heard about it so
what is that in it for you members of
the teams that adopt a ops culture lead
a more balanced life spend more time and
automation infrastructure improvements
improvement and automation bringing more
better quality outcome on a continual
basis will be the motor will be the
thought process spend less time fighting
fires I am not reactive a more proactive
then this will lead towards looking at
what is that typical DevOps oriented
teams looks like they spend more time
doing positive or neutral tasks they
automate repetitive tasks they bring in
improvement infrastructure and
applications they educate themselves on
continued basis actively learn so that
will become an organization which is
leading towards the success achieving
their goals so you as an individual
become our of organizations vision and
vision and direction row actively I will
not name the organization it's about one
month back I was conducting one of the
best practices sessions and it not it
evokes some other topic when I just
asked the question what is the vision
mission and direction of organization
they had no clue and this particular
group of them group members are the one
who are actually the leadership player
who are about to influence the thought
process with an organization and ill the
next level organization to the direction
required by organization so when they
don't know consciously vision vision and
direction of organization where is that
organization would lead towards this is
because they are very reactive and this
this I have evidenced in not in one
organization most of the organization I
come across that I
and please improve croscill knowledge of
tools and technology and continuous
basis the tool may be there in the
organization to may not be there better
your herbal and nonverbal communications
appreciate the feedbacks and
acknowledged accordingly have least NT
say hello thinking this is one of the
biggest threat in the organization what
happens if I share the knowledge is
someone what happens if I do it this way
what happens if I share the secret of
doing certain way of things the moment
that contribution stops things will not
fall in place so have this attitude
adoption culture automatically things
change in the organization which is very
essential cooperate and collaborate and
now I cooperate but my colleague doesn't
cooperate I cooperate my manager doesn't
cooperate so there is a challenge what
is there for long and will be their
throat but this will become successful
only when organization comes forward and
say we need to do it and who can make it
happen you everyone in organization who
can make it happen who has to come
forward what water okie says was from
amazon the traditional model is that you
take your software to the wall that
separates development and organization
sir operations the traditional model is
that you take your software to the wall
that separates development and
operations and throw it over and forget
about it this is what a traditional
model but it is not at amazon what
Amazon's upset you build it you run it
this is the culture amazon are dogs so
why it adopts this brings developers
into contact with the day-to-day
operations of their software it also
brings them into day-to-day contact with
customers when developers are in
connection with customer they understand
the customer's pain when operations are
in can in close association with devs
then this in the dynamics there and
contribute there as well and all of them
are away the dependency is gone
individuals dependency is gone customer
is happy customer is benefited because
they one offs or together collaborated
in such a way that outcome which is
coming out is coming out the way
customer needs so there is a saying
don't you me what you have give me what
I want which is a critical thought
process to be enabled in every
individuals in organization to make it a
successful organization so final word
it's all about you above principles and
practices affect organization culture
change and continuous improvement cannot
happen without the support of people
like you so take action take action to
transform from non DevOps environment
where there is no collaboration more
silos towards DevOps environment where
there is better collaboration and no
silos and with this I think we can where
I would end the webinar and open up the
question s please let me know if you
have any questions and queries what I
can clarified so that you can better out
of the DevOps and take it forward so I
just look at the chat or otherwise I
what I will do is there are 47 attendees
may be difficult to unmute everyone and
listen to the questions let me look at
in the chat window if there are any
question asked so then I will move
towards next so charge ok questions
don't we feel this integrated d am I see
approach for lean time the for project
management is Lee nice very well
appreciated and DevOps is please adopt
that particular things that's why we saw
the three best practices related to any
organization which has to be adopted for
its success we saw us one is itsm it is
ideal d am I see to Six Sigma approach
what you're bringing and that is lean
methodologies anyway similarly a jet so
bring in the collaboration of all these
three rather than being in a separate
silos it is idea so one has a question
now develop it into a jail and other day
methodologies do offs does not fit into
a jail DevOps says bring in more agility
into entire product lifecycle not just
for development so DevOps is no
different than any best practices
instead they was looking product
lifecycle or service lifecycle as a
whole and bringing out the collaboration
in terms of agility in terms of quality
in terms of service management practices
in terms of operations in terms of
making business successful now next
question is will you get the copy of the
slides so i think you should ask the
coordinator from simple and write up a
meal or click the help and support and
just ask the question so that if there
is a possibility they would shade with
you then is there a standard
certification for DevOps if s please let
me know on the
same so DevOps foundation is a
certification offered and this debuffs
either is owned by institute called
DeVos Institute who has who authorizes
the Institute's like simply learn to
conduct training and to provide
certification examination so simple
learn is training provider has well as
examination provider also you can get
trained by simple learn and also book
exam with simple on for divorce
foundation so currently offered
certification is at foundation level
that is DevOps foundation so is there
any industry certification for drops i
think answered this I see it raises
scariness for QA as there will be no
more q a vertical separately when
divorce what's your experience so this
is what typical fear people has in the
last session one person asked me I heard
the moment DevOps comes up we will show
are we going to lose the job now tell me
if I look at from the day I shared my
profession unless there is a specific
scenario like what happened in I think
2009 there was no other scenario or 99
or 2000 that was a dot-com bust so other
than such significant thing there was no
job losing happen they were nobody lost
the job when you want of new way of
doing things it is insisting you to
learn more and more proactively and keep
contributing to organization so that
will ensure your sustenance and it is
not sustenance you are commanding over
your own ability and capability and
challenging yourself and moving forward
which has a space for you in the
industry and organization and
organization needs such people such
capable people and the people who are
such attitude organization is that ok
nage a project we perform all these
divorce goals so how does DevOps head
value that's what I mentioned agile you
do it focusing on development alone but
in DevOps you are not focusing only on
development part of it you're focusing
on the entire lifecycle product or
services to bring in that by bringing
the collaboration of agile lean and
ideas and practices simple and get a
certificate for individuals who undergo
the training and I think newly simple
known has come up with that the policy
that to enable individuals to learn to
support them to the implementation so
that you need to
implement this somewhere and showcase
the power practice what you have done
and the simpler will issue a certificate
related to the topic you learned so how
do we know more details of divorce water
certifications involved the
certification is there a foundation and
it is currently offered certification
for Dov's with the product life getting
low and low nowadays how have these to
use of divorce so that is a reason
DevOps came up because the life cycle
the life of products are not too long
quicker changes is happening DevOps has
come in to address it so other a
different roles in divorce like how
scrum scrum master these specific rules
the DevOps that's why I think I
explained in the last slides there is no
specific role as such individual has to
adopt that thought unless to see
anything you do there should be an
ownership and accountability that
accountability is missing nothing can
move forward so this accountabilities to
brought in by assigned individuals for
that particular cultural moment once
cultural moment is in place it is
everybody's job to rob dyrdek culture
and more supporting each other ok I'm
going to test management working in
united kingdom how devil foundation
certificate will hire value to my
profile so anyways practices knowledge
like devops again will evidence because
i will tell you one one thing about
certification because of this question I
never appreciated certifications toward
my life until I come across a customer
who made one statement we were an
organization I was adding the
deliberative vision there who has done a
fantastic job in many projects and
services no customer wanted us because
of the way we do things but customer
said I cannot select you because my
corporate expects the individual in your
entity to be certified in any of the
best practices like itl PMP prints too
agile etcetera now that tray made me
realize a certification brings in a
value a brand value telling that is have
undergone this knowledge and I know it
consciously so that will create a
platform so for you when you undergo
devops it will create a platform for the
individuals in the industry to look at
you and how you perform this is another
point which you need to enable yourself
and demonstrate it but certification
enables you to go to that particular
platform so that is
the value of any certificate respect a
certificate so i finished question I
feel DevOps will help for operations and
they will be happy while in this mode I
would guess quality compromise
unknowingly how to ensure this doesn't
happen when interrupts yes you are right
okay I'm into QA and in my organization
I have to step up my environment wearing
we have to set up the DB server and
weblogic server and all as the quality
me for DevOps kind of a role no i did
not get this question this was asked why
happy shake I went to QA and in my
organization have to set up an ornament
wherein we have to set up the database
server and the weblogic server and all
does this quality me for divorce kind of
a role the last part is very difficult
for you to understand a shake if you are
a repo [ __ ] please repost is what I
understand an answer okay so then I will
move to the next question if any
questions are there think that's all the
questions are so mother haces did not
answer my questions what was your
question Maharaja you explained it
yourself let me look at it again I feel
DevOps will help for operations and they
will be happy okay while in this mode I
could kiss quality compromise
unknowingly okay how to ensure this
doesn't happen when develops okay you
are saying devops thought will apply for
quality and unknowingly there is a
compromising of quality the very nature
the very requirement of DevOps is to
have dev and offs both of them come
together educate themselves become aware
of both other side of the story and
cooperate and contribute to each other
and here consciously you say quality is
going off and you are seeing it seeing
and saying here which means you are
aware of it quality is compromised and
why that quality is compromised that is
a question students why the quality is
compromised and that has to be addressed
and is that because of there is proper
knowledge transfer to the operations or
operation is not aware of anything what
it is and this another confusion or
wrong understanding DevOps is for
operations it is not DevOps is for
everyone okay there is another
golden circle golden Ruby speaks a war
which is ace anything you do first ask
the question why unless you ask the
question why your action does not make
sense so the moment you answer why your
action is towards that why by answering
next questions how and what why am I
doing this to achieve something ok I
will I achieve it what should I do to
achieve it along welcome outwards but
the very reason the why if you don't
answer however you have how many number
of answers for water and how does not
make sense so it is very important to
first to answer why now DevOps also what
is it divorce and why do I need divorce
in my organization that we need to
understand why do officer citizen I
explained you first all of us know
product lifecycle all of us know
development all of was no testing all of
us operations but the gap exists to fill
the gap to reduce the gap we need
divorce way of thinking how to ensure
quality does not compromise in divorce
so there is a business direction if
business says I can compromise this to
at this level that is a great level of
quality once it is agreed there is no
look back it has to be achieved okay
this is for product development how it
is useful for product support so product
development is def part of it I think
this is so please question so supple
answering equation product development
is a dell part of DevOps and product
support is off spot of DevOps you are
speaking about have a collaboration with
the both and bring out the result which
is needed for the business okay which is
next question fried do go pee through
copy which is a question do you think
agile methodology and DevOps going and
to and our management planning to
implement a jail and also develops how
does it go well with a child okay
through the to answer your question it
is not the implementation of a child and
devotes a jail thought process what you
do in development by adopting a jail in
development bring out that similar
thought process throughout the product
lifecycle bring in agile lean itsm
practices across the product life cycle
so today's best way of doing things
which is realized is agile methodologies
and they a gel is within the ops and it
is not limited to product
when it is a cross I hope you got the
clarity a burger okay thanks mother with
a DevOps applicable to maintenance as
well or just for development projects
it's for entire product lifecycle of
service lifecycle mother that's what I
just explained further ago okay so any
more questions cyber therefore next five
minutes so please let me know if any
questions you can answer before I
conclude the session okay feisal thysen
as DevOps implements principal from a
gel in the itl what are the core values
and principles of DevOps so corvallis I
showed camps what we discussed culture
automation measurement and sharing this
is the core value of divorce and that
has to be kept in mind while doing it is
it clear if ison we discuss that core
values when we actually went through the
webinar enter the session it's about
cultural required culture for
organization which is collaboration
communication integration required
across it's about bringing in automation
it's about bringing in the measurement
Roger whatever I do I'm were to measure
there is no second thought about it and
last one which we discuss about is
sharing consciously sharing and bringing
up the people around me and people
around me are well aware of I am also
lifted further all right thank you so
much for the participation and I wish
all the success for your learning
requirement please be in touch with us
and have a wonderful learning experience
for yourself keep learning keep growing
and have a wonderful week ahead
you